[Música]
o professor allan russell que ensina
cirurgia e engenharia química na
universidade de pittsburgh acredita a
para o futuro que a medicina
regenerativa vai acontecer medicina
regenerativa é basicamente a utilização
de biorreatores que vão construir novos
membros com novos órgãos ou seja quebrou
danificou a gente põe outro equivalente
no lugar
nas palavras dele isso ajudaria a
substituir medo por esperança medo
porque quando vamos ao médico existem
palavras que simplesmente não queremos
ouvir câncer esquizofrenia alzheimer ou
no diagnóstico de um filho autismo
paralisia cerebral esclerose lateral
amiotrófica todas as doenças
debilitantes e até então considerada sem
cura pela medicina
e eu digo isso não como pesquisadora
como professora ou como o cientista
eu digo isso como quem viveu a perda de
um pai há três semanas atrás vendo na
uti de um hospital
debilitado mas em situação clínica de
diagnóstico diário equivalente à de
tantos outros pacientes que
continuamente eram trazidos de volta
cada vez que tinham seus dados vitais
rebaixados mas meu pai não porque
simplesmente a medicina não sabia o que
fazer com ele
e de acordo com alguns juristas trazer
de volta uma pessoa para a qual não se
tenha cura é considerado não eutanásia
mas de está na ásia que na interpretação
da lei significa não um prolongamento da
vida mais um prolongamento da dor e do
sofrimento e da morte
isso nos traz para a medicina atual
aquela que frente a uma situação de
doença sem cura
a gente explica aquilo que é o
estadiamento ou seja um estudo sobre os
sintomas e uma aplicação de tratamento
sobre os sintomas e não sobre a doença
em si e na adaptação de um ser humano a
uma nova forma de viver
face a um tratamento a gente tem a
tecnologia
assim a tecnologia assistiva é uma forma
de adaptação a uma nova maneira de viver
de uma maneira mais branda bom
acontece que quando a gente fala de
tecnologia medicina saúde agente
automaticamente fala de custo de fator
econômico e aí um estudo do professor
hans rosling médico e estatístico mostra
aqui
a partir de 1.800 do tando 200 países e
acompanhando os por 200 anos
num gráfico entre expectativa de vida e
renda
nós saímos de 30 anos de expectativa de
vida para os países em 1800 até uma
média que vai entre 55 e 85 anos nos
anos de 2018 ele ficou mundialmente
conhecido por essas bolhas
ele pinta os países de cores de acordo
com o seu continente a américa verde
áfrica azul e esse estudo nos faz pensar
que quanto mais rico um país maior a
expectativa de vida e quanto mais pobre
a menor expectativa de vida alguma coisa
aqui no brasil a gente conhece bem
falando em brasil vamos ver os dados do
brasil pelo professor hans rosling ele
coleta a partir de 1900 e tenha uma
queda lhe um pontinho verde em baixo que
é equivalente à primeira guerra mundial
onde a situação do mundo inteiro em
termos de saúde de caiu e ele chega aos
75 anos em média que é o que se espera
da vida no brasil
bom isso nos faz pensar em algumas
inferências a primeira é se nós sabemos
qual é a idade em que se provavelmente
vamos perder uma sociedade um povo a
gente começa a saber a doença que a
gente precisa estudar porque ela está
causando o rebaixamento a nível de óbito
a nível de 1
a segunda inferência é que nós
precisamos ser mais ricos para podermos
ter acesso à longevidade com qualidade
de vida
bom como professora de um centro
universitário do norte do país
a gente fica pensando o que é possível
fazer para que a gente consiga chegar lá
uma qualidade de vida superior que
precisaria de um país com mais recursos
financeiros
e se a gente pensa no brasil a gente
começa a imaginar a realidade do nosso
país em termos educacionais culturais
políticos e consequentemente econômicos
ea gente começa a ver que a gente está
um pouco longe disso
vai demorar algum tempo e é melhor
deixar isso para lá então o que nos
resta é contrariar o professor hans
rosling e começar a pensar numa
tecnologia acessível que faça com que a
gente consiga chegar à longevidade sem
tantos recursos financeiros
surge assim a e desde 2008 o jetta o
grupo de estudos de tecnologia assistiva
incentivado por um então aluno matheus
santos que hoje é colega de trabalho e
que
simplesmente pensou comigo em montar um
grupo que utilizasse a acessibilidade do
ponto de vista econômico ou seja
economicamente viável e para isso nós
temos que contar com alunos porque reúne
pesquisadores renomados também
implicaria em custo
precisaríamos utilizar tecnologias
atuais e isso não necessariamente era um
problema porque eu sempre acreditei que
essas tecnologias do futuro estão
disponíveis agora a inovação raramente a
tecnologia a inovação vem da forma de
conseguir entender um problema e aplicar
a tecnologia como uma forma diferente de
resolver aquilo que se fazia antes de um
outro modo ea gente precisava conhecer
então essa demanda regional para que a
gente pudesse desenvolver tecnologias
utilizáveis nos interessava desenvolver
pesquisa para publicação científica para
paper para artigos aprovados em
congresso
a gente queria fazer isso com tecnologia
nacional que também e implicaria num
baixo custo e com uma equipe
multidisciplinar
ou seja a gente precisava reunir o pouco
que a gente sabia de tecnologia com nada
que a gente saber de medicina de
fisioterapia e terapia ocupacional
alguns projetos surgiram como por
exemplo o quarto dimensão uma solução
assistiva que viabiliza a automação
residencial para pessoas como a suellen
a suelen tem esclerose lateral
amiotrófica e é uma pessoa fantástica
que nós tivemos oportunidade de conhecer
no último ano a carinha dela ali e o que
nós fizemos foi a partir de um headset
com eletrodos nas extremidades não
invasivos nós dávamos a suellen a
possibilidade de ser um pouco mais
independente ou seja o herói do lateral
amiotrófica é a uma falha no neurônio
motor ou seja o corpo não obedece mais
os comandos do cérebro embora o cérebro
esteja preservado o cognitivo dela está
intacto
essa doença ela ficou mundialmente
conhecida por conta do físico stephen
hawking que perdemos o mês passado
aquele da cadeira de rodas e através de
um eletroencefalograma em tempo real
aquele que nós vamos fazer nas clínicas
médicas a gente conseguia fazer um mapa
cerebral ou seja eu poderia treinar
pessoas a um padrão de pensamento ea
partir de um pensamento repetitivo do
tipo acenda uma lâmpada eu conseguiria
fazer a identificação desse mapa
cerebral e desenvolveu um software que
identificasse que reconhecesse esse
padrão cerebral e mandasse um comando
atrás de automação para um dispositivo
então a gente começou a treinar isso com
a suelle e
há uma curiosidade se eu pedi pra
qualquer pessoa se concentra em acender
uma lâmpada automaticamente a pessoa vai
querer olhar para a lâmpada e mentalizar
a senda lâmpada acenda lâmpada e isso
não acontecia com a suellen a suellen
ela quando era convidada a fazer esse
tipo de teste
ela simplesmente conseguia apagar e
acender lâmpadas ou mudar o controle
remoto de televisões sem precisar olhar
com aquilo atrás dela por exemplo no
quadro de cima a gente vai ver a suellen
ascendendo a lâmpada e apagando a
televisão a partir desse headset desse
controle
nós perdemos a suellen ano passado
aos 24 anos bom um segundo produto
assistiva que desenvolvemos foi o
brincando com a leitura
desenvolvemos em parceria com a
universidade do estado e ele é um
aplicativo baseado em método fônico que
ensina alfabetização para crianças com
paralisia cerebral
quando a gente pensa em paralisia
cerebral a gente normalmente pensa em
comprometimento motor
só que pessoas com paralisia cerebral
também têm algum tipo de comprometimento
de atenção de concentração e isso fez
com que a gente da área de tecnologia
começará a se entender uma nova forma de
design porque a princípio esse design
no mínimo questionável mas quando a
gente começa a encher de muitos detalhes
a princípio de bom gosto visual para uma
criança com paralisia cerebral a atenção
dela vai se desviar e é tudo que nós não
queremos no processo de alfabetização
conseguimos ainda colocar aquilo que os
psicólogos analistas do couro do
comportamento chamam de reforço positivo
mas que pra gente da área da tecnologia
significa game ficação que é colocar
aspectos de games técnicas de games em
alguma coisa que não é um game e aí
conseguimos ensinar através de etapas
que chamamos de níveis e dar banho
bonificações scor pontuações cada vez
que a criança passava de nível com isso
gerávamos um banco de dados que dava ao
fisioterapeuta ao terapeuta populacional
ao fono dados como o tempo de jogo que
traduzindo significaria o tempo de
aprendizagem e aquelas etapas em que a
criança mais demorou a prender ou
precisou repetir e isso mostrava
eficiência dessa forma de aprendizagem
bom ganhamos alguns prêmios com isso e
há três anos atrás
começamos a nos perguntar o que era tão
importante a gente desenvolver
tecnologia economicamente viável quanto
espalhar essa idéia
e aí a gente lança a proposta de pedir
ao ted internacional uma licença do ted
x do pedex esse evento que a gente está
aqui hoje e que veio também de
iniciativa do jetta
nós queríamos compartilhar idéias e
queremos fazer isso da nossa cidade da
nossa sociedade
bom a gente conseguiu e alguns números
do jet que são do pedex mostram mais de
11 milhões de inscritos no canal da
gente no youtube e mais de mil downloads
do brincando com a leitura além de todos
os outros dispositivos e softwares que a
gente desenvolveu e que estão
disponíveis gratuitamente nas lojas
virtuais
esse é um dos últimos trabalhos que
desenvolvemos o alzheimer vr em parceria
com a clínica de fisioterapia do nosso
centro universitário do cesupa a gente
conhece o alzheimer como sendo uma
doença que causa esquecimento de fatos
de pessoas só que a gente acaba
esquecendo que existem alguns sintomas
transversais como irritabilidade
agressividade e depressão
há o que nós tentamos com esse
aplicativo era estimular pacientes com
alzheimer a fazerem fisioterapia que são
repetições muitas vezes enfadonhas de
movimentos para alguma motivação a mais
que proporcionasse algum tipo de
entretenimento no meio de uma sessão de
fisioterapia que em geral é indicada
pelos médicos porque na manutenção do
movimento a gente consegue fazer com que
o paciente de alzheimer
não esqueça coisas como subir uma escada
ou como se usa uma caneta que também é
esquecido para pessoas com alzheimer
a gente colocou uma biblioteca gráfica
aqueles pontinhos verdes ali que
conseguem a partir de uma câmera comum
captar os movimentos e da profissão a
terapeuta informações do tipo amplitude
do movimento largura do paço e nós
levamos isso para dentro da clínica de
fisioterapia lá nós experimentamos a
solução com a dona adelina ali 85 anos
diagnosticada com demência do tipo
alzheimer com a alteração postural
alteração de equilíbrio e lentidão da
marcha passos curtos e um quadro
depressivo
nós colocamos a imagem de uma valsa e
testamos o protótipo nela sem nenhum
tipo de comando a dona adelina levantou
e começou a dançar o nosso acadêmico de
fisioterapia correu e abraçou com medo
que ela caísse
eu acho que dá pra perceber a carinha de
emoção das pessoas que estão lá né
observando e também dá pra perceber que
o vídeo é curto porque logo depois a
dona deolinda centor e nós corremos
pensando que ela tinha se machucado que
alguma coisa tinha acontecido e ela veio
explicou pra gente não minha filha eu
parei porque eu me emocionei
eu lembrei de quando eu dançava nos
salões da sociedade com o meu marido já
falecido
bom mas eu não posso esquecer que sua
professora então eu preciso compartilhar
com vocês o melhor dos meus resultados
os nossos alunos que conseguiram provar
que desenvolver tecnologia assistiva
economicamente viável sem grandes
recursos é possível porque é possível
desenvolver qualquer coisa com vontade
de fazer a diferença
a gente só não consegue desenvolver nada
sem vontade e na figura dele eu agradeço
a todos aqueles que acreditam que a
partir da educação a gente consegue
transformar uma sociedade ea nós mesmos
profissionalmente e pessoalmente porque
ninguém termina uma experiência dessas o
mesmo obrigado